so jetzt lasst es euch schmecken das ist
heute ganz was besonderes es ist die
original hausmacherin zu Befund
hatlinger den happlinger macht die Suppe
einen guten Abend
[Musik]
ja
original hausmacherin hatlinger gegessen
hat der ist keine andere Suppe mehr
warum irgendeinen Scheißdreck fressen
wenn es auch die original hausmacherin
gibt
ja stimmt
das ist die original hausmacherin Suppe
von happlinger und laut Drehbuch sollen
sie die Suppe essen und ein begeistertes
Gesicht machen und dann sagen hey ist
das was Gutes da können wir ja gar nicht
genug kriegen Original
hausmacherinsuppe von hablinger denn und
so weiter und so weiter
aber warum sie diese Suppe probiert
also noch mal
hausmachersuppe die zweite
und bitte
[Musik]
ja da hören sie selber wer einmal die
Original hausmacherin zu Befunden
Hattinger gegessen hat der ist keine
andere Suppe mehr warum irgendeinen
Scheißdreck fressen wenn es auch die
Original hausmacherin zu Befunden gibt
der war schon sehr sehr viel Schönes
dran mir fehlte so ein bisschen die
Begeisterung okay also nochmal noch mal
von diesem flüssigen drecks trägt
Friesen
jede Idee die Suppe in dem Topf die
sieht man ja nicht wenn ich dort
hausmachersuppe die dritte
von herblinger gegessen hat der ist
keine andere Suppe mehr warum
irgendeinen Scheißdreck fressen wenn es
auch die original hausmacherin gibt
oh ist das was gut da kann man gar nicht
genug kriegen
Original
[Applaus]
[Musik]